Welcome back to Things You Missed, and prepare
yourself to relive your childhood nightmares
because in today’s episode we’re looking
at the teasers for Scary Stories To Tell In
The Dark.
Stick around to the end of this video if you
want to hear how these classic stories tie
together in the new movie.
At the time of making this video there are
four teasers for Scary Stories To Tell In
The Dark and they are filled with references
to the original trilogy of children’s horror
stories.
I was more of a Scary Stories for Sleepovers
kind of kid myself, maybe a little Goosebumps,
but I’m definitely interested in the new
movie because the teasers look intense, like
they’re aimed for kids who grew up with
these stories and are now adults.
Let’s take a look at the first clip.
"Based on the iconic book series.
Scary stories."
The creature in this teaser is a recreation
of the monster from short story called The
Dream which appeared in Scary Stories 3.
The tale is about an artist named Lucy who
goes from town to town to paint various villages.
She decides to go to a village called Kingston,
but the night before leaving, she has a dream
about this pale skinned woman in warning her
to flee while she can, that this is an evil
place.
So the next morning, she wakes up and decides
to go to a different town, Dorset.
As she’s looking for a place to stay in
Dorset, looks at a room that resembles the
room from her dream, which makes her uneasy.
The landlady goes to make some tea and give
Lucy time to think it over, when the pale
skinned woman appears before her, sending
Lucy running for the hills.
In the movie, the creature approaches a boy
down a long hall with a red light, which tells
us that the movie may not just be an anthology
of scary stories adapted into short films,
but rather that the stories exist as stories
within the world of the movie, and maybe the
characters find themselves in trouble when
they discover that these stories are true.
Another story from the book is showcased in
the next teaser.
"Scary stories."
The story is called The Red Spot, and it’s
about a girl named Ruth whose face is paid
a visit by a spider as she sleeps.
The next morning she notices a red spot on
her cheek that looks like a spider bite, but
instead of going away over time, the spot
grows until one day, it bursts while she’s
in the bath, and tons of baby spiders come
crawling out because the boil was actually
filled with spider eggs.
In the movie, the girl discovers a spider’s
leg in the red spot before it bursts.
And she’s in high school when it happens.
The roof tiles are similar to those in the
first teaser, leading me to believe they could
all be in this school together.
If you know anything about the Scary Stories
books, you probably recognized the next monster.
"Who... took... my... big... toe?"
This is the first story in the first book,
in which a boy pulls out this toe from the
woods, and he brings it home and for some
reason his Mom prepares as part of her soup…
and they eat it for dinner.
If you never want to have soup again, I completely
understand.
But not much is different here in the movie,
because the next thing that happens is the
monster then comes after the boy.
The monster in the book is also described
as having a huge mouth and teeth to chomp
it’s victims’ bones, but the movie version
looks more like The Green Giant.
The last teaser is a little bit more ambiguous,
it has the boy from the first teaser, who
keeps saying, “we’re next”, and then
this other kid is attacked by the Green Goblin
looking-ghoulo.
I don’t think there’s a specific story
or piece of artwork that this guy is from
in the books, so my guess is that this is
one of the many unseen monsters from the stories.
Probably 30% of all these stories in those
books follow the exact same formula where
someone’s in a spooky house or location,
and they hear something coming towards them
and getting closer and closer and then whatever
it is that’s making the sound disappears
and the story ends.
So my guess is that this friendly looking
guy is one of those monsters, but this time
he comes and breaks down the door.
There’s also this other shot in the teaser,
this last one is just packed with stuff, and
it appears to be water dripping into a horse
trough.
There are three stories with horses in the
series, one where a witch turns a man into
a horse at night, one where two kids are attacked
by a ghostly tribe of men on horseback, and
one where a fortune teller predicts that a
man’s horse will lead to his death, which
is most likely what we’re seeing here.
So how are all of these stories going to connect
to make a movie?
According to the studio, a group of teenagers
in the 60s discovers a book of stories whose
legends begin to turn real, resulting in horrific
deaths across their town.
So I think they’ll discover that the tales
of horror read about in the books are the
key to overcoming these monsters in real life.
Let me know in the comments if there are any
stories you’d like to see incorporated in
the movie, and remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
and ring the deathbell for notifications,
so you don’t miss out on upcoming Things
You Missed episodes like the Scary Stories
Official Trailer.
And if you love short horror stories click
the playlist on the left to listen to some
creepy stories that I’ve written.
As always, I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.